quelques années ont passé les visages
ont changé mais l'énergie est restée la
même Martin Manon et Idris vous ouvre
les portes de leur kebab en toute
tranquillité
[Musique]
je suis Benjamin pallier je suis
réalisateur je suis éducateur en média
au collège Sainte-Thérèse de Rambouillet
et cette année avec mes élèves de
l'atelier cinéma nous avons réalisé une
série qui s'appelle au calme oklm qui se
déroule en 7 épisodes cet épisode de 5 à
6 minutes et qui sont diffusés
prochainement alors cette série elle
raconte l'histoire de deux jeunes
adolescents donc un garçon et une fille
Nathan et Enola qui se rendent tous les
jours au kebab pour prendre le repas et
qui ont une certaine relation avec le
gérant du kebab ou la gérante et qui
demande des conseils donc le but c'est à
la fois pédagogique et artistique
artistique puisque les élèves demandent
l'atelier cinéma font à la fois derrière
la caméra et devant la caméra et
pédagogique puisque la série chaque
épisode de la série aborde un sujet
différent lié à l'adolescence donc par
exemple la première épisode c'est sur le
stress de la rentrée le deuxième sur le
téléphone portable il y a aussi des
épisodes sur le divorce sur le
harcèlement scolaire enfin on essaye de
traiter différents sujets de
l'adolescence à travers cette série mais
toujours avec une certaine légèreté
voilà le but c'est de d'essayer de
donner des conseils aux jeunes qui nous
regardent mais toujours avec un esprit
comique donc cette série a été réalisée
donc avec 10 adolescents que j'ai dans
mon atelier cinéma la plupart des scènes
ont été tournées au collège
Sainte-Thérèse de Rambouillet il y a des
scènes qui ont été tournées dans le pari
du Château de Rambouillet ou or sur la
petite place juste devant le collège